So you have a great
idea for an app that's
going to run across mobile,
tablets, laptops, and PCs.
And after you've done all the
hard work of designing the UI,
now it's time to get to
the really hard problems.
That is, how do you get all
of these devices communicating
between one another.
It's time to take
advantage of the cloud.
Acting as a central
resource each client
can use the cloud to
send and receive messages
keeping all the other clients
in sync with each other.
But not every cloud
is created equal,
you'll want something
that's easy to use,
won't become an ongoing
maintenance headache,
and of course,
scale, just in case
your app becomes a
smashing success.
Enter Google App
Engine, which makes
it easy to build scalable
cloud solutions for web
apps and mobile backends.
App Engine reduces the pain
of building these solutions
by providing a suite of
powerful usable services,
and it also reduces
deployment panes
by automatically
running and managing
your applications for you.
This ensures that
your app always
has the right amount
of server capacity
to handle your traffic, not
too much, not too little.
But back to the point, you're
building the next great app--
how can Google App
Engine help with that?
Let's say user a wants
to send a message user b,
but user b isn't
currently online-- we're
going to need some place
to store the message.
The App Engine Data Store is
the easiest choice for this.
It's part of App Engine
so it's ready to use
with no configuration
or set up needed.
You hand your data
to App Engine and it
takes care of replicating
it to multiple data
centers across
the world, so it's
always available to
your global customers--
no scheduled maintenance
or configuration headaches
required.
But best of all
the Data Store will
continue to scale whatever
size your app needs.
As you write more data,
you get more capacity
all without having
to lift a finger.
And of course storing messages
is only half the problem, when
user b comes back
online, you'll need
to retrieve any messages
waiting for her.
And to do this you'll
need to server logic
to fetch the right messages
for the specific user
and return them to the
appropriate client.
And thankfully you can author
that server side logic in one
of our many supported languages
like Java, Python, Go, and PHP.
Now as the number
of your users grow
you'll notice that
your app often ends up
fetching the same data over and
over and over and over again,
frankly some data's just
more popular than other data.
Fetching this data does take
a bit of time and computation,
and repeated fetches
have the same information
is hugely wasteful.
To avoid melting your servers
with wasteful fetching,
App Engine provides
a feature to improve
retrieval speed
called, Memcache.
Memcache allows you to store
commonly accessed data in fast,
in memory distributed
cache, so your app
isn't sitting around waiting
for a bunch of data store rights
or for some business
logic to execute.
Also did I mention less melting?
That's a really important part.
Of course besides the
Data Store and Memcache,
there is a plethora of
APIs at your disposal,
but that's another video.
Anyhow, back to your app--
using Data Store and Memcache
you can store and
retrieve data quickly.
The runtime logic allows you
to specify customer request
handlers so your client gets
exactly the responses they
need, however you don't
always want your clients
to wait around for server
side logic to finish.
Sometimes you want the
server to do some work
and you want your clients to
come back later for the result.
For example processing an upload
video or applying an awesome
filter to a picture of a
soon-to-be-eaten entree.
These high-compute operations
take a bit of time to finish
and leaving the client
connection opened
during this time can chew
up your users' batteries
which doesn't make for
great user experience.
Plus there's probably
work your app wants
to do when no one else is
around like gathering statistics
of how many of your
users are interacting
with one of your new features.
To help with this, App
Engine provides the tasks
API, which allows
you to schedule work
to be run later or in
the background which
is important to keep your
user's battery from melting
while waiting for the
server to finish work,
but that's another video.
At this point you have a
basic app set up and running.
As your app grows,
you'll probably
want to add support
for binary files,
like a user profile photo or
some awesome homemade music.
Now while the Data Store is
built for structured data,
it might not be the right
place for binary files.
As such, it's to look deeper
at your storage options.
Google Cloud Storage is up
to this particular task,
allowing you to store an
unlimited number of files
or objects up to terabytes
in size that are available
globally, each with the access
controls that you specify.
And so far we've talked
about how App Engine scales
on the back end,
but it's also worth
pointing out how
App Engine provides
another invisible layer which
helps your app scale as well.
You see App Engine
provides a dedicated
layer of Front Ends which
make sure client data get off
the internet and on to
Google's network as quickly
as possible, while also making
sure that your code and the App
Engine run time don't have
to wait around for slow
or poorly connected clients.
Now don't forget,
your clients can
talk directly to
many of the back end
services without needing to go
through your server side code.
For example, your user can
upload an image and data
directly to Cloud Storage
or grab structured data
right from the Cloud
Store API and even
talk directly to
the tasks API to see
what pending work is
available for processing.
Before you go running
off to build your app,
there's a bit of planning
that needs to happen though.
Namely as your service
or back end changes
over time keeping your
Android, web and iOS
clients in sync
with those changes
becomes a really gnarly task.
To help with this,
Cloud Endpoints
makes your life just
a little bit easier.
You simply define
your server API
and the Cloud Endpoints will
generate the client libraries
for you, which not only takes
care of data serialization
but handles the connection
and minimizes transport
bloat across the wire.
With all of these features
and services and your command,
Google App Engine allows you
to build the next great app
and scale it big with the least
amount of trouble for you.
See, building the next amazing
app is as easy as that.
Now go build something great.